Thanks all. I want to understand how sourcing actually works today, not how the
policy says it works. Tom, can you start — walk me through a typical event.
Sure. Requirement lands with me, usually as an email from the business, sometimes
a conversation in the corridor. I write the spec up properly, build a comparison sheet in Excel,
and then I email each supplier individually with the requirement.
Responses come back to me. I put them in the sheet. Nobody sees the bids except me
until I've made a recommendation. Which — yes, I know. Audit flagged that. They flagged it last
year as well and nothing happened.
And how long does a typical event take, start to award?
Two weeks if everyone plays ball. Longer if I'm chasing. Three, four weeks is not
unusual.
What about the second round — when you go back to a shortlist?
That's a phone call. Always has been. That's — I mean, that's the job, isn't it.
That's where I actually earn my money. You don't get another four percent out of somebody through
a portal. You get it because they know you and you've got a relationship.
To be fair Tom, we've been told the new system does have a negotiation round
built in. So it's not going away exactly.
A round. Structured, with a timer on it, and everything I say written down. That's
not negotiating, that's an auction with extra steps. I've been doing this nineteen years and I've
never closed a deal by typing.
That's useful, thank you. Sarah, is it the same picture in Indirect?
Broadly. I use templates a bit more, and I do get a colleague to sanity-check
the comparison before I go to award. But it's the same tools — Excel and email. There's no system
in it at all.
Same. And the contract goes in the shared drive at the end, under the supplier
name, and then honestly you forget about it until something goes wrong.
How many events would you say the team runs in a year, across all four categories?
Team-wide? A hundred and forty, hundred and fifty. There's eight of us. Call it
twenty each, roughly.
It's more than that though, isn't it. That's the ones we log. If you count the
small ones, the three-quote jobs where you just ring round, it's closer to two hundred. Maybe
more. We don't put those anywhere.
And where do those smaller ones get recorded at the moment?
They don't, really. They just become a PO.
Understood. Coming back to the new process — the design has a hundred thousand
euro threshold above which a competitive event is mandatory in the system. How does that land?
That's already the policy. Has been for years. The difference is nobody could
check before and now the system won't let you past it.
Which is fine in principle. In practice it'll mean an event for things that don't
warrant one, and the business will scream about lead times.
What happens today when something genuinely urgent comes up and there's no time
for a competitive process?
You ring Helen and you get a waiver. It's a conversation.
And in the new world, is there a waiver route? Does anybody know?
No idea. Nobody's said.
I assumed there would be one but I've not seen it written down.
Noted — I'll take that away. Last thing from me: what would actually make this
better for you? Genuinely.
Not building the comparison by hand. That's two days of my week gone, every week,
copying numbers into a spreadsheet. If the system does that I'd take it tomorrow.
Knowing when contracts expire without having to go and look. That would be worth
a lot.
Look — I'm not against it. Get the admin off me and I'll be the first one cheering.
I just don't want to be told the relationship part doesn't matter, because that's the bit that
gets the price down and it's the bit that took me twenty years to learn.
Sorry, joining late. If it helps — the last ERP go-live, we had two days of
training six weeks before and then nothing. Half the team never used it properly. Whatever
happens this time, that can't be the plan.
That's very helpful, thank you. Anything else anyone wants on the record?
Just that we've not been asked about the scoring criteria and I'd like to be.